now look at the numbers from the last
election no matter how you
read them no matter how skeptical you
are about the numbers
under no reading of the numbers does
last
november's election qualify as a blowout
as a
mandate for change it just wasn't
historically speaking it wasn't even
close
to a mandate and yet you'd never know
that by the way the white house is
behaving completely remaking the country
in less than six months
newest example joe biden's budget
proposal it includes about
5 trillion in new spending and targeted
tax breaks to
friends and family over the next 10
years now that's on top of the 5
trillion the government has already
borrowed during the covid pandemic
from china this budget also includes
13.2
trillion in planned borrowing
where are we going here how does this
work
does math still exist ryan reitel is a
senior fellow at the manhattan institute
and fluent in mathematics
he joins us tonight to assess this brian
thanks so much for coming on
what's in this budget and what would
happen if it passed
this budget is remarkable by any
historical standard
we've already spent two trillion dollars
with the march stimulus
the biden budget would add five trillion
dollars in spending on top of that
over ten years and then there's another
five trillion dollars in
new proposals that are going to be
coming from the biden campaign
and fake expirations you put that
together
you get 12 trillion dollars in new
spending
over 10 years to put that into context
that is
eight times bigger than the cost of the
2017 tax cuts that we were told we can't
afford
another way of throwing a big number out
at you is
before the before the pandemic the
national debt was just under 17 trillion
dollars
if you assume the entire biden agenda is
enacted
and the new proposals come the debt goes
from 17 trillion before the pandemic to
44 trillion
at the end of of 10 years this dwarfs
anything we saw not only from republican
presidents
but even from obama clinton you have to
go back to lbj to see anything like this
i mean this is really i mean of course
lbj was prosecuting a major war in
southeast asia at the time
this is wartime spending we're in one of
the longest
non-war periods in modern american
history we're not fighting a war really
right now they're assuming we never will
be or there won't be any other
interceding crisis that deserves our
attention and money i mean on what
assumptions are they basing a budget
like this
this is the rosie scenario this assumes
that we have quick growth no more
recessions
no more wars in fact that defense
spending drops slightly
relative to the baseline it also assumes
interest rates stay low so that we can
keep borrowing
cheaply because it assumes that today's
low interest rates never rise
by the way if interest rates do rise
every single percentage point adds 30
trillion
dollars in 30 years in interest costs so
this is the rosy scenario this is growth
no recessions no new wars low interest
rates
you still have a debt going from 17
trillion to 44 trillion
let me ask you super quickly you've
you've read this budget is there
anything in the budget that does not add
to the democratic party's power
very little i mean this is this budget's
a democratic wish list
there are slush funds everywhere you
know one of the things the president is
proposing
is essentially a trillion-dollar
corporate welfare slush fund
where we would raise corporate taxes
five times bigger than the tax cuts they
got in 2017
and then put some of it into a corporate
welfare slush fund
that if companies do what bus do what
government wants them to do if they do
what the biden administration wants to
they would give them about a trillion
dollars in corporate welfare spending
this is part of the infrastructure plan
i don't know what part of infrastructure
corporate welfare is
but there's huge huge slush funds for
government
and you know that's a good way to get
big business on board with the
democratic agenda is to tell them
you're on board we'll give you money
back
exactly paying off your friends throwing
your enemies in jail
brian great to see you john thank you
for that thanks tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else